NARRATOR: The
following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: This is my lecture
on section 6.1 of the notes.
Really, the central problem
of numerical linear algebra is
solving A*x equal
b by elimination.
That's what is used much more
often than anything else,
but we're talking about
sparse matrices, large sparse
matrices.
That's what we have in
mind for a long time now --
probably all lectures coming up
-- thinking of those matrices.
And this is the prototype
of a large sparse matrix.
The main point of
the lecture is,
if you take the unknowns in
whatever order they're given --
here I took them numbering along
the rows -- one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight and so on --
you got to stop and think
or get the computer to look
at reorderings, because
the reorderings can make
an enormous difference
in the fill-in.
So this is, actually, the key
word for this lecture, is --
and the key concept is the
fact that as elimination goes
forward, a lot of these
zeros become non-zeros.
Let me see it
happen, first of all.
So this is the whole
idea of fill-in.
What's going to be the
very first entries that
are filled in?
Let's see.
I guess that the very
first row operation,
if you took the matrix like
this and did elimination, 4
is the first pivot.
You would add 1/4 of the
first row to the second row
to make that a 0, right?
Then what would happen?
This would change that number,
but this would put a new number
in there.
So a new number
would appear when
we do that first row operation.
And then, also working
with this pivot,
I would operate on that
row to make this a 0,
and then this would change,
that would fill in, right?
I guess that this
already has something,
so that won't be new.
So each of those steps, each
of those row operations filled
in a non-zero and reduced
the sparsity of the matrix,
and the sparsity is
what we're living by.
Now if I continue and
continue, we'd need MATLAB --
to use spy in MATLAB to see what
the picture would look like.
It's very interesting to see it.
Spy shows you the non-zeros.
We're very much
focused on what's 0
and what isn't 0
in matrix entries.
We actually keep track of that,
the structure of a matrix,
as well, of course,
as separately keeping
track of the actual numbers.
One place, we're keeping
the actual numbers,
but in the decisions
on ordering,
we're only interested
in zeros and non-zeros.
So let me look even
more at this fill-in.
Now, you saw it happen up there.
Let me just look at a
single fill-in step.
So I have a row j
and a row i, and this
is going to be the pivot that
I'll use to eliminate this,
but in this row, there's another
non-zero and in this row,
the k-th entry is
not non-zero; it's 0.
So this is what we start
with prior to elimination,
just as we did there.
I just want to see
-- focus on small --
on the fill-in occurring.
Of course, this isn't
on the diagonal.
This is in column k,
which is somewhere far
out in that case, somewhere
close by in that case.
But we're just -- this
is on the diagonal.
That's the pivot, the j-th
pivot, that I'm ready to use,
so I subtract a multiple
of that to remove that.
So what does -- elimination will
not change the pivot row and it
will produce a 0 there,
that's the point.
Then the real point
that I'm making
is that when I multiple
this by the right number
to produce 0 and do
this subtraction,
this 0 disappears,
that fills in.
That's some a_(i,k) new that
-- the new value in row i,
column k is not 0.
so we see that -- as
we saw it for numbers,
here's we're seeing
it symbolically.
Let me see it graphically,
because everybody sort of --
to visualize the big picture.
I think everybody
finds the graph
description of the non-zero
structure the simplest
to imagine.
So the graph for this
little problem would be --
so what's the graph that tells
me where the non-zeros are?
Again, it doesn't tell
me what numbers they are,
just tells me where they
are, which positions.
It's only the positions
that I worry about
in deciding on the
ordering to use.
Then I execute using
the actual numbers,
but in deciding on the ordering,
it's just the position.
So I think of my graph as
having a node for every row.
So that's node j for row j.
This is node i for row i.
Somewhere we'll have a node k.
So, at the start -- so
those are the nodes.
What are the edges?
There is a non -- so the
edges come from the non-zeros
in the matrix.
So there's an edge from j
to k, because this is not 0.
There's an edge from
i to j or j to i.
I'm not worrying
about the direction --
this is not a directed
graph right now.
So this is the start, but
there's no edge here initially,
because a_(i, k) is 0.
Now in this graph
world -- it's so small,
we can just focus on the
part that's going to change
a little.
The rest of all the other
rows have their nodes
and all the other non-zero
entries have their edges.
So this is a tiny
part of the big graph.
What happens to this tiny part?
So again, I want to see the
same elimination step, just
this way, in the graph world.
So after, what edges are there?
So again, it's j, i and k --
and after I do elimination,
j is still connected to k.
That's still there.
No change.
j is no longer connected
to y, because elimination
killed that edge, but
elimination created
a new edge, i to k.
So that's essentially
what elimination does.
Maybe we can say it in words.
When this edge disappears,
at the same time
we create new edges
connecting any two nodes that
were both connected to j.
You see that point?
If I'm using j as the pivot row
and I look on that row and say,
what non-zeros are there?
What edges are connected to
j, and I see one -- and then,
when I do elimination,
I'm going to introduce,
exactly as has happened here, a
new edge between any pair that
were both connected to j.
So we're kind of fighting
against creeping filling.
The question is,
what order should we
do these eliminations?
So now, think of a larger graph.
Actually, I guess we could
somehow think of that --
we can try to visualize
it, but maybe not succeed.
So the graph for that problem --
could that serve as the graph?
I guess it could, really.
I would remove -- I'd
[? whiz ?] away the --
if I'm given the values
on the outer edges,
then I would remove all
those, but essentially,
this is the graph for
that matrix, right?
If I number each of
the nodes 1 to 16,
and I would do the numbering
the way I did to produce that
matrix -- now the
whole question is,
if I do some different
numbering, will --
that'll shift around.
That'll just be a
permutation matrix, right?
If I do a different
numbering -- so matrix-wise,
I have my matrix K2D -- what
happens matrix-wise for --
if I do a numbering, a different
numbering, a reordering?
That just permutes the
unknowns and the equations.
So really, what happens is
some permutation multiplies
K2D on the left and its
transpose does the same thing
to the columns on the right,
because this permutation
will change the order
of the equations.
This permutation will reorder
the columns to come back,
to bring the diagonal
back onto the diagonal,
but in a different order.
We won't know it with all
those 4s, but that will have,
again, all the 4s on the
diagonal, but the minus 1s
are moved around.
Of course, none have disappeared
or been created by that.
It's just that's
giving us a new order.
So that the reordering
matrix-wise.
What's the reordering
graph-wise?
Graph-wise would be, instead of
this numbering of unknowns --
one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight and so on --
nine, ten, eleven, twelve,
thirteen, fourteen, fifteen,
sixteen -- we have a different
order, different numbering.
The computations, the computer
science aspect, you could say,
was not going to be difficult.
Actually, we should think and
maybe we'll think in a minute,
from the computer science
aspect, the actual execution --
I'm probably not -- certainly
not going to write out
a permutation matrix.
That's ridiculous.
I'm not going to draw a
graph and keep that --
I'll keep some list of
positions for non-zeros,
so we'll say a word
about that list later.
Here I'm trying
to say, how do we
get an idea of what the
effective reordering is
and what a good
reordering would be?
So here, this is a
specific reordering
that I want to
mention right away,
because it's so straightforward.
You can get the idea of
the red-black ordering
without any big computations.
This is the --
fundamentally, the winner.
This is what people use all
the time and MATLAB's backslash
is going to have that available.
Inside this, the
codes that are called
are the column or
symmetric matrix,
approximate minimum degree.
So that's what this AMD means
-- approximate minimum degree.
So that's the basic
idea that I'll
come back to as
soon as I've just
drawn the red-black picture.
It's so important that
people don't stop thinking.
So another sort of
high-level picture
of how to do an ordering is
look for graph separators.
That's become a big step in the
world of computational graph
theory, and that leads
to something called
nested dissection, which
is separators of separators
of separators, the usual
keep going with the same idea
that you see in algorithms.
What about red-black?
Red-black, I'm simply going
to imagine that this is
a checkerboard -- it's the
nodes that I'm looking at, not
the squares.
So that's red,
black, red, black.
So I'm going to number first --
I'm going to take all the reds
first, so I'm changing this
number now to take all the reds
-- one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight and now all the
blacks -- nine, ten, eleven,
twelve and so on.
I'll stop there so your eye
will know how to fill in.
What's the point of that?
If I take a red node and look --
suppose this first one is a red
node, as it is -- then what
do I know about the positions
of those minus 1's, the
non-zeros in the matrix?
They're associated with
black nodes, right?
The neighbors of this
node number one are black.
The black ones have numbers
from nine to sixteen.
So then the black --
everybody sees it.
With this molecule that has a
4 in the center and minus 1's
beside it, those minus 1's
are associated with nodes
of the opposite color.
That's what we see here
in the actual numbering.
So what does the matrix become?
What does this -- if
I do that permutation,
the permutation that's
associated with that
renumbering -- what
will the same matrix --
here's the same matrix, but now
I'm permuting it and so what
does it look like?
Maybe I can draw it smaller.
I think I probably can.
So in this pretty special
situation where the red nodes
are not connected to any other
red nodes, only to themselves,
I think I'll only see the
4I -- this is red to red.
Those are the eight red nodes,
an eight by eight identity
matrix times 4.
The blacks are only connected to
the black and all the minus 1's
are in our connections
between red and black,
that is, this far off the
diagonal, what shall I call it?
B I'll just pick a letter --
B and B transposed probably,
because I know the matrix
is going to stay symmetric.
If it started
symmetric, as it did,
then this operation of
reordering rows and columns
compatibly is going
to leave it symmetric
and it must look
something like this.
Is that matrix more
sparse than before?
No.
It's got the same minus 1's.
They're just all pushed
up into this corner.
Will it have some
fill-in as we go forward?
What's the answer on that one?
As I go forward,
maybe I should --
I haven't really
thought that through.
My instinct is yes.
We'll have fill-in.
Will we have more fill-in
or less fill-in than the row
by row ordering?
I should know the answer.
I think I'd probably ask
the machine to tell me.
My guess is probably
not more and we can --
why do I think probably
this is better?
Of course, I should
know exactly.
In general, it's better to put
off the evil day -- that is,
this goes through the first
half of elimination -- I mean,
you know what I'm thinking here.
All the off-diagonals
have been sort of
pushed down in the matrix.
Let me do an example that
shows why that's good.
Suppose my matrix has a non-zero
diagonal -- and by the way,
the first step in the good
codes for elimination do
a permutation exactly to
produce a non-zero diagonal,
so you're OK to start.
You know where you are.
Now suppose that the
non-zeros all show up --
and I'll make the
matrix symmetric.
That's the non-zero
pattern and my point
is, that's a very
good non-zero pattern.
Why is it good?
It's good because there's
no fill-in whatever.
When I subtract
some multiple, when
I go to make this
0, to eliminate it,
I subtract a multiple
using the first pivot.
It changes that, but it
doesn't fill in anything new.
The only operations required
are operating on the last row,
which is already full.
So there's an example in
which the bandwidth -- see,
normally the bandwidth
is a good guide --
but that's only for
pretty full bands.
Here's a matrix that's
not banded, really.
Its bandwidth is the full five.
I have to go out five
columns until I get the last,
until I get the non-zeros.
So that is a big bandwidth.
So bandwidth w, the
bandwidth w is large, but --
it's the perfect
ordering -- but no fill.
I don't fill anything -- you
realize that for banded matrix,
we won't have fill
in outside the band.
Our concern is for fill-in
inside the band and here,
we don't have any, because
the bad row -- and actually,
it often happens in some least
squares and other problem that
you might -- this isn't quite
as stupid a matrix as you might
think.
These might be blocks
rather than single entries.
You often want to think
block-wise about a matrix.
You might think,
why would you have
a matrix that was well separated
with block diagonal, which
is really good, and then
a few rows that are full.
That seems sort of unlikely, but
I guess I want to say it isn't.
If you had a problem in
least squares minimizing
some expression
involving that matrix,
the block diagonal part,
but with the constraint
that maybe the sum of all
the unknowns has to be 1,
then when you use a
Lagrange multiplier to bring
that constraint
into the problem,
into the matrix, that's
going to show like that.
And the beauty of the
Lagrange multiplier device
is that, also, that it'll
produce a symmetric column
there.
We'll see that in the third part
of the course, but I'm just --
my point is that this example is
not as artificial as it seems.
Now suppose we had taken
the bandwidth as our metric,
as our goal.
In reducing the
bandwidth as our goal,
we would have made
a bad mistake.
If I wanted to do a permutation
that reduces the bandwidth,
I better put this up in
the middle somewhere.
So this is -- that bad row
comes up in the middle and then,
I guess, these are
maybe whatever --
I guess I need
three X's down here.
I'm going to do the same
permutation from the right,
so that will move this
column over to the middle.
This would be a reordered --
this would be a P matrix P
transposed thing, I think.
It's got a better
bandwidth, right?
Now we have -- we're totally
confident of all these zeros
here.
But it will fill in.
Where will we get
fill-in, in that matrix?
So as we start, we're using
elimination to remove those
entries, no problem, because
that upper left corner is
the way this big,
the whole matrix was,
no fill-in up to there, but just
as soon as we reach this one
as our pivot row and use it to
subtract multiples to knock out
those, when I make those
0 by using that pivot,
it's going to bring the whole --
this will be gone at that time,
but this will be non-zero and
that will produce new edges
in the graph.
Might be fun to look
at the graph that
is associated with this
matrix and its permutations.
But anyway, you see that
this will all fill-in.
So again, in that
small problem, we
could really see
what was happening.
In the big problem,
we can almost
see it when we take a very
specific, highly structured
permutation like red-black,
although I haven't pinned down
exactly what the
count is like now.
I'd be glad if somebody would
just run a computer experiment,
count non-zeros, count -- yeah.
So what's the good
thing to count?
How do you see what
the fill-in finally
was when you've
done an elimination?
I guess that the L
and U factors, which
is what elimination
produces, that's
where the fill-in will be.
So maybe I just make
that point, so that you
could make these experiments
that I have in mind
and tell me what I
ought to know about it.
So if I have the matrix
K, whichever it is --
whether it's this one or
this one or any other,
then the effect of elimination
is to factor it into a lower-
times an
upper-triangular matrix.
I'll just mention a
special case while I'm --
special positive
definite case --
we can adjust it so that's
K is L times L transposed.
This is called Cholesky.
We can arrange the
-- it will happen.
We can arrange the scaling so
that by putting the square root
of pivots with L and the other
square root with L transpose --
so Cholesky is a MATLAB
command, C-H-O-L, and actually,
MATLAB -- if you give
MATLAB a symmetric matrix --
if you give MATLAB a matrix to
work with, it will first ask --
it will ask, is it symmetric?
If it is symmetric, it will hope
that it's positive definite,
so it will begin Cholesky.
It'll begin to look for this --
it'll begin the factorization,
which is perfect for
positive definite ones,
until it succeeds and finishes
Cholesky or until it discovers
that nope, a negative pivot
appeared, which signals,
that the matrix is not and
was not originally positive
definite and then MATLAB
has to accept, OK,
now I may have to
do row exchanges,
pivoting operations
and all the rest.
So MATLAB's sort of
optimistic until it --
on a symmetric matrix
until it is told otherwise.
But not all matrices
are symmetric,
so this would be the general
case, almost the general case.
I haven't included
here the pivoting,
the row exchanges
that MATLAB does
as it executes elimination.
So let me just finish
my sentence on L
and U. L will have
the fill in, in it.
L will tell us -- and
U will, certainly.
I mean, they both will.
U will have these -- that guy is
going to be part of U and this
one is -- I expect to
see something there in L.
So L and U will actually
exhibit the fill-in,
so that you could find out how
much fill in there is simply
by counting the non-zeros
in the matrices L and U.
This is to encourage you,
because this is really
a pretty experimental subject.
Nobody -- the best
methods, which --
or the favorite method.
I think nobody can say best,
but this approximate minimum
degree, the favorite method,
we could prove some theorem
to show that it was better
than something else,
but to really see,
is it successful
or not on a wide
variety of problems,
that's really experimental.
Just try it.
Now what does it mean?
So I looked at
that specific one.
Now I'm ready to look at the
approximate minimum degree,
and I'll contrast it with
the perfect minimum degree.
There are codes for that
and those A's become M's.
But it turns out -- and I don't
know exactly why it's the case
-- that the approximate minimum
degree usually, if anything,
it's superior.
So these are the ones to use.
So what does
minimum degree mean?
Minimum degree means
-- let's see --
if I took this problem -- I
should draw the graph for this
matrix.
So what does the graph
look like for this matrix?
I've got six nodes -- let
me put six nodes in --
let me put five and the node in
the middle will be the one that
they're all connected to.
In this ordering, those would
be one, two, three, four,
five and six -- and all the
connections go into six.
So that's the graph
for that matrix.
The graph for this one -- so you
probably see it better than I
do.
What I had originally there --
I guess this is the graph with
the numbering one, two,
three, four, five, six --
what was there before
the fill-in happened?
The graph would look
the same, but the nodes
would have a different
numbering, right?
One, two, three,
four, five, six --
so shall I just put
the bad guy here?
One, two, three, four, five,
six and then what's the point?
As soon as I use number
three to eliminate four --
three was connected to five, so
a new edge is going to appear
there.
Three was connected to six,
three is connected to four.
When I use it, a new four,
six is going to appear.
So those are a couple
of the fill-ins.
Those are the two
fill ins in row four.
Then when I go onto row
five -- I'll fill in there.
So those are the three
below the diagonal
and above the diagonal,
non-zeros that come
from the bad ordering, I think.
I didn't prepare that,
so I hope it's right.
Yeah
So what's minimum degree?
Minimum degree is simply sort
of a greedy type algorithm.
We have no way to
look far, far ahead
and see what non-zeros are
coming way, way down the line,
so let's just take
it where we are.
We have to choose what
should be the next pivot.
Let's say we take
that first pivot.
Good.
So what are the
degrees of these ?
Let me redraw the graph
before the fill-in.
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
So I've got six nodes.
That has a degree 1.
It's connected only
to one other node.
Actually, all these
have degree one
and this one has degree five.
Five edges are going out.
So the whole point of minimum
degree is, don't pick that one.
At each step, create
the new graph.
The graph expresses a fill-in --
and we're not going to be able
to avoid some fill-in,
normally -- but at every point,
take the graph as it is and
choose as the next node to work
on -- that means the next
row to use in elimination,
the next pivot to choose --
choose one that has smallest
degree.
Don't choose this one.
So for this very
special case, we
have five choices
for what comes first.
We make a choice like that one.
We do elimination.
In this case, it doesn't
fill in anything.
Now I'm looking at
the rest of the graph.
I have four nodes there with
degree only 1 and a node
there with high degree,
so I don't choose that.
So I choose 2 and so on.
So of course, minimum
degree, approximate
or perfect or any
dumb idea is going
to create the right ordering
that produces this matrix.
I hope you see what
minimum degree is.
At every stage, you look down
the column, just as here.
Actually, what would
minimum degree give here?
I would love to have
a complete picture.
I think we could at
least see at the start.
Let me erase this
red-black ordering
and prepare to write in a
minimum degree ordering.
If I can re-complete that graph.
So what node do I take first?
Remember, the graph really
does not have these pieces.
I might as well erase them now.
Shall I just erase -- these are
pieces that connect to known
values that are on
the right hand side.
So I think the graph doesn't
have those connections,
those connections -- it's going
to look pretty much as it did
before, but I think now we
have the graph of actual 16,
the graph that we
should be looking for.
That's the graph of
our matrix, the graph
of the nonzero
structure in the matrix.
So what do you take
as the first node?
You take the corners, right?
The corners are going to win,
because they have degree 2.
These guys have degree 3.
There's a degree 2, so I
might take that -- let's see,
what happens?
When I take this one,
then I have to see,
when I use that as the pivot
-- exactly what I did here --
what's going to fill in?
I guess explicitly I know
that two new edges fill in
and what are they?
Maybe they're the same.
I guess they are.
This is edge number
-- on the graph,
it's probably easier to
see than in the matrix.
So I use this guy.
By elimination, I'm
removing the connections,
so it maybe sits
there, surviving
to remind me which
node was numbered one,
but these connections have
been removed by elimination.
That entry became a 0 and
that entry became a 0,
but there was a
fill in here, right?
That's the first step
of minimum degree.
The second step, as
you say, I'm going
to do all the
corners first, right?
Because that has degree 2 and
these still have degree 3.
No improvement.
It's kind of fun to do.
Two and that filled in.
Number three and that filled in.
Number four and that filled in.
What next?
There are going to be
a bunch of choices now.
As far as I know --
I could be wrong --
I don't know whether the --
I don't know what the choice
decision -- how the decision
is made when there is a choice,
when I have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight nodes, all with degree 3.
Let me just take this one.
So I'll take this as the next
one, as number five, I guess.
That'll be number five.
That will kill all
those connections
and just leave the node,
but it will put in that one.
Any others?
Maybe only that one.
Did I do that right?
I mean, it would
have put in this one,
because those are both
connected to this,
but that edge is already
in there, so nothing new.
Actually, here I've created
a node that is also degree 3.
So I'm going to have a
lot of degree 3's here.
But then, after a while, I think
when I get into the center --
I'm guessing that the
degree will go up.
I don't think I get away
with degree 3 all the way
until the finish, I don't think.
Anyway, you see the
point that there
are choices to make, among
nodes with equal degree.
Then there's this calculation
to make -- maybe I should --
this is a moment to just
mention, if I can do it,
how you might keep -- how
you might organize this pass
through -- so this pass
through the matrix --
it's really a just a
pass through the graph.
It's not looking at
the actual numbers.
It's just choosing the
ordering and then the next pass
through we follow that
ordering with the numbers,
finding the multipliers
that go into L
and the numbers that
are left in matrix U.
So how would I -- how would
anybody reasonably write down
the original list?
So I have the nodes numbered
one, two, three, four --
up to sixteen.
Those are the node numbers.
Now with node one,
I'll list all the --
so this corresponds to
row one of the matrix,
so I'll list all the nodes
that are connected to row one,
to node one.
Node one itself is -- I don't
know whether to put that
in or not.
Maybe I will.
Number two is connected to
it and number five above it.
I'm taking the
original row ordering.
Then when I look at node two
-- this is going to be a long
list, but I'll have to have
a break there to tell me that
these numbers were
associated with row one.
Now I want to know those
associated with row two.
So row two had the
connection back to one,
so this little group is going
to be all the things connected
to row two.
Remember -- sorry, since I've
erased all those connections,
but you remember them --
two was connected to one,
it's connected forward to three
and above it to probably six.
Maybe that's one,
three, and six.
And then a slash, and then
whatever node three --
so I need -- I guess I need one
more line there to tell me --
I need a pointer.
I need a line, a pointer
that tells me, number one,
start with the first
one -- one, two, three.
Number two, start
with the fourth one.
Number three, start
with the seventh one.
So that number seven is
pointing to the beginning
of the sub-list, the
beginning of the short list
that's associated to
each separate node.
I guess what I'm
saying is that this
is a pretty compact
description of the graph.
This will tell me all
the edges in the graph,
It tells me what
two is connected to
and this tells me where
that little set lies.
Now if I, as I will,
change the ordering,
then I just reorganize
the pointers.
I'm going to speak
roughly and not
the details, just in
general, in the large,
you could imagine that this is
a pretty convenient structure
to use for keeping the record
of what the node numbering is.
The command nnz is a useful one.
That's a MATLAB command that
counts the number of non-zeros.
So n, n and z suggest
exactly what that will do.
So if you pick an ordering,
like approximate minimum degree,
and you pick a matrix, like
this one, and you run --
I've been very
interested in that.
You take the matrix, K2D,
you take the permutation
that comes from approximate
minimum degree, that gives you
this reordered matrix.
We then do elimination, which
factors it in L times U --
probably L times L transposed,
because it's a positive
definite.
Then I would do nnz of L
as a measure of fill-in.
That would count
the fill-in in L,
and with symmetry,
it'll be the same in u.
If you have a better idea than
approximate minimum degree,
that's a measure to
use as the criterion.
I've just a little
time to speak, finally,
about this idea of
graph separators.
So again, I have to
get back to a graph.
Let me draw a graph under.
So now I'm ready for this one.
I'll put a little
star next to it,
to say that it didn't
look for a long time is
if it could compete
with number two,
because it'll be a
different ordering.
You could, in a way -- it's
going to be a block minimum
degree order.
Let me say what it is
and as I draw the graph,
let me say when it might win.
It might win when the
size goes way up, 3D.
In 2D, minimum degree is
-- on sparse matrices,
is quite successful.
So in two dimensions, until
the size really gets big,
that's going to be fine.
In three dimensions -- I'm
still going to draw only two,
but in three dimensions or
very, very large matrices,
I want to think about
this graph separator.
So let me -- I'll make it
just so I really separate it
perfectly -- let me
make the number --
so when you look at that
graph, you might say, if I --
look at that set of nodes.
So a separator is
a set of nodes that
separates the rest of the
nodes into two groups.
So I have a group of nodes
P, a group of nodes Q
and nothing, no
connections between P
and Q. P is this part.
Q is a similar part over there.
S, the separator, is the
part with the connection.
So P is connected
to Q only through S.
So now if I think of ordering,
in what order should I
take the P, the Q and the S?
Our absolute rule is,
everything's connected to S,
put it last.
So you see that this is the
block form of my small example
here.
I didn't particularly
have a P or Q,
but I certainly
wanted to put S last.
Maybe I did.
So maybe the separator here
was -- so what's the separator?
One possible separator
would be like that, as S,
P for these two nodes,
Q for these three nodes,
and the rule would be -- I
haven't said what I'll do
within P or within
Q or within S,
but the rule would
be put Q last.
Of course, that was exactly
the right thing to do.
We're following the same
rule, just block-wise.
So we have the --
so our matrix --
what does our matrix look like
when you choose this ordering?
You have whatever P is,
the block of all these P's.
You have the block of
all these Q's, which
might be connected to each
other and are, but not to P.
So the main point is,
you have these 0 blocks.
And then everything
is connected to S
and S is connected to itself.
So all you've achieved, but
it could be considerable,
is to take an ordering
in which P was --
since P is not connected to
Q, that produced these large 0
blocks and of course, they'll
stay 0 as elimination goes
forward.
those 0's there will -- I
don't have to do any pivoting
operations, any row
operations to make those 0.
They're already 0 and
so the only operations
will be P onto S, Q
onto S, S onto itself.
In many problems, it's
the S onto itself part --
so what will happen then,
when I do elimination on S?
When I do elimination -- I'll
have whatever work is necessary
within P, so I'll be factoring
-- can I call that P,
that part of the matrix?
It's an abuse of notation.
This is the
connections of S to P.
This is the connections of
S to Q, S to itself, Q to S,
P to S -- probably symmetric.
So when I do elimination --
if I don't, if I accept this
ordering -- if I accept this
ordering and just go for it,
elimination will
factor P into L*U --
because it'll work up in the
corner as it always does --
then there's no connection here,
so it'll factor Q into its own
LU, and of course, all that --
all this stuff down here will
change, but effectively these
will become 0's, because then
there's a serious elimination,
P onto S, will make that 0.
Q onto S -- Q will make that 0.
This will be some
-- I'll call it SSS.
It's a much fuller matrix,
block -- smaller though,
hopefully smaller
-- but pretty full.
So actually, in the graph
separator nested dissection
world, most of the time is
spent on that third block,
just working with
it, because it's
the one that's pretty full.
So how do graph separators work?
First of all, you
need an algorithm
that finds the separator and
a lot of computer science
attention has gone onto that.
Given a graph, cut it in half.
We don't want more
nodes in the separator
than necessary, because the
work is going to end up there.
So we want to cut the
graph pretty nearly in half
by a short separator.
If we only did the dissection
once, that's what we need,
but this idea of
nested dissection --
you know what's going
to come before I say it.
The idea of nested dissection
will be, take this,
take the graph -- can I just
draw it this way without
drawing all the edges?
Cut it by a separator S_1.
That gives a P_1 and a Q_1.
But now, what's coming?
You're going to separate P_1.
In order to do the work up
in that left corner for the P
matrix, that's itself
a sparse matrix, so now
I'll look for a separator
and what separator
will I choose for the
left side of this graph?
I'll choose the
horizontal separator.
This will be the
second separator.
It'll separate
the two bits of P.
The third separator will
separate the two bits of Q.
Now I have this part to work
on, a fourth separator will --
you'll see its a nested.
These separators become nested.
There's S_5, there's
S_6 and so on.
I think everybody
sees in principle
what nested dissection should
do and the question is, how does
it compare with minimum degree?
You see, it's just
like a different --
we're off on a
different route here.
You can compute
asymptotically for large N,
what power of N appears
there, what power of N appears
in minimum degree -- but I
would love to know, does the --
I would be happy if somebody
used approximate minimum degree
on our model problem and maybe
also on some other problem.
We could see what power of
N -- that's essentially what
we're looking for.
So it's N to what power for
fill-in and for the operation
count, which -- the
number of flops,
which controls the
cost and the time.
So it's what power
of N appears there
and what power appears
in any other method.
There you have it for
direct elimination methods.
I'll just mention
the name of the --
guy's at University of
Florida, and he's the one who
contributed the code that
MathWorks uses and has just
announced a book coming
on this exact topic,
to come later this
year from Sci Am.
So there will be a
book from the person
I take to be the leader in
this algorithmic development.
Just to remind you,
Friday is my guest,
former PhD student who is
going to speak about numerical
methods for finance --
Black-Scholes equations
and other problems to find the
value of financial derivatives.
See you Friday.